[Music]
hi i'm stephanie and today i'll be
showcasing the digital shopping journey
of a beauty consumer and how retailers
can improve customer experience and
engagement
with the kovin 19 outbreak and resulting
disruptions consumers were left
homebound for days at a stretch
a recent google survey shows beauty
consumers initially purchase less
products
but recently have a revived interest in
beauty categories
like makeup sunscreen and shampoo
they've also shifted heavily towards
online purchasing
of course with online shopping consumers
are experiencing the same pain points
that have always come with beauty
shopping
it's hard to choose the right product
envision the product on themselves
and decide on a product without prior
brand experience today
i'll show you how you can empower your
customers with a seamless online
shopping experience
and carry them from product discovery to
consideration to purchase
meet mary mary is a marketing consultant
by day
even though her city does not have a
shelter-at-home order in place
mary is working from home but summer is
here and mary has a socially distant
picnic planned for this weekend with
some of her close friends
it's outdoors and feels relatively safe
she plans to wear a mask on her way to
and from the park
but she also wants to look great on her
rare day out mary decides to experiment
with a dramatic look for her eyes
to start mary searches youtube for a
daytime eye look and finds a full
tutorial on it
she loves this look on the influencer of
course but she's not sure it would work
on her
luckily she notices a try it on button
under the video
she's able to try on the look on her
eyes and even experiment with different
colors using a built-in
augmented reality feature looks like the
blue really pops on her
all of this works using machine learning
and ar core
the technology dynamically detects the
user's face shape and
attributes rather than static images
this allows you to create rich
engaging experiences for your customers
and with an integrated shopping button
users like mary can quickly land on the
shopping page
to check if the eyeshadow will suit her
skin tone mary can simply head to her
integrated digital shopping assistant
and ask that question using voice the
assistant can also show her reviews
and answer any common queries with a
digital shopping assistant
you can introduce new interactive ways
for your customers to experience your
brand
dialogflow is the underlying technology
for the shopping assistant
and can be used to easily train a
chatbot on your product graph
for a specific skew from product details
or frequently asked questions
mary adds this item to her cart and as
she does that mary receives
recommendations on additional products
to buy
retailers today are increasingly
centralizing their user data
in google's bigquery data analytics
platform and then building
personalization
and recommendation models on top of this
data
here we're able to take a look at her
previous purchase history
as well as the items in her cart to
provide more relevant recommendations to
complete her purchase
as mary scrolls through the frequently
bought together and other items of
interest
she remembers she could replace her
cleanser she searches for dry skin
cleanser
and adds to her card additionally
she remembers she is running out of her
favorite sunscreen so she clicks on
vision search
and simply snaps a picture of the
sunscreen container that's right next to
her desk
she uses it to search for the product on
the retailer website
and it matches with a click today's
retail search is keyword centric
driven largely by manual merchandising
rules matching tokens or words in the
query to data in the catalog
and use of limited data from retailers
logs
google cloud search for retail provides
retailers with high quality product
search results
for their websites and mobile
applications users can begin a query via
voice
image text and barcode and get to their
choice of products faster
with everything she wanted to buy and
more mary finalizes the time that works
for her
for curbside pickup at her nearest store
and wraps up by paying with g
pay contact list feels good not just in
store but
online too now all she needs to do is go
pick up her order
thankfully the store was just a mile
away with integrated maps she can easily
find her way
for her scheduled curbside pickup right
from her confirmation mail
beauty shopping made fun and easy most
of mary's journey is on the site
so why have a disconnected experience
before reaching the site
mary's journey demonstrates how google
cloud's aiml-powered products and
solutions
can create a more seamless user journey
and captivate customers with engaging
and hyper personalized moments
what are you solving for to learn more
about google cloud's retail solutions
check out the link here
you